notre focus du jour nous conduit
aujourd'hui au pakistan quatrième
producteur mondial de lait ce géant
démographique est aussi l'un des
principaux consommateurs de produits
laitiers la production est
essentiellement artisanal elle échappe
largement au contrôle sanitaire 80 % du
lait sache est effectivement en vrac il
est non traités une aubaine pour les
producteurs et les revendeurs crapuleux
qui en vue de faire gonfler leurs
bénéfices vont même jusqu'à parfois créé
le relais à partir de produits chimiques
ces pratiques désastreuses sont un
véritable fléau pour la santé publique
voyez un peu ce reportage de chaïb walla
et sonia ghezali
le pendjab est la première province
productrice de lait au pakistan 80% de
la production laitière est entre les
mains de petites exploitations
familiales comme celle de mohamed njim
il gère avec ses frères cette ferme
laitière dans la famille depuis trois
générations
il possède une cinquantaine de vaches et
du buffle qui lui donne environ 1000
litres de lait par jour c'est un buffle
d'eau sont les ai vendu à 150 roupies le
litre la qualité de son lait bien
supérieure à celle d'une vache que les
plus épais bourré de nutriments une fois
que vous commencez à boire du lait
l'eyrieux flou ne pouvait plus jamais
revenir au lait de vache
depuis quelques années ce fermier a du
mal à joindre les deux bouts la crise
économique au pakistan accentuée par la
pandémie de kobe 19 a fait exploser les
coûts de production pour augmenter ses
ventes mohammad nadim ajoute cette eau
du robinet à son lait il ignore tout
pourtant de la qualité de celle-ci
connaît pour être formulée
voilà comment nous couperons le lait
avec des lots j'ai ajouté 10 litres
d'eau à 30 litres de lait cette façon je
peux gagner 50 roupies de bénéfices par
l'it
en 2015 l'entretien des bêtes et de la
ferme nous coûter moins cher vous pouvez
économiser beaucoup d'argent grâce à
cette ferme laitière mais maintenant les
dépenses ont presque doublé on est passé
de 80 mille roupies à 150000 l'inflation
dans le pays a augmenté donc la seule
façon de bien faire du profit c'est de
rajouter de l'eau
il livre aux commerçants mais aussi
directement aux habitants de son village
en magasin le lait en brique vos 165
roupies le litre soit 85 centimes d'euro
cet euro n'ont pas les moyens de se
l'offrir alors il se fait livrer chaque
jour un litre de lait par marine nadim
je paye 130 roupies le litre je sais
qu'ils mélangent le lait de vache et le
lait de bufflonne il ne m'est rien
d'autres avant eux nous achetions du
lait dans une ferme dans notre rue
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'ils
ajoutaient beaucoup d'eau le fermi ne
des trompes à son client au sujet de la
composition du lait qui vivent
70 % du lait en vrac au pendjab contient
des traces de produits chimiques et de
bactéries nocives pour mettre un terme à
ce fléau l'autorité alimentaire
provincial organise des contrôles est
clair sur la route aux entrées de la
ville le contenu des pots à les
intercepter est passé au crible
tous les mois un échantillon
l'un d'eux vous dois me suivre nous
devons écrire vos coordonnées pour la
traçabilité de votre lait
madame voici les champions les
échantillons de lait prélevés sont
analysés dans ses laboratoires mobiles
les résultats sont obtenus en 15 minutes
qui est le transporteur de ce lait votre
lait de qualité inférieure il contient
25 % d'eau autre valeur nutritionnelle
faible la teneur en matières grasses et
faible aussi cette fois ci nous vous
laissons repartir avec une amende
seulement mais si vous recommencez nous
jetterons tout votre lait et nous
déposerons plainte contre lui
l'homme devra s'acquitter de 3000
roupies d'amande soit 15 euros son nom
figure aussi désormais dans une base de
données de l'autorité alimentaire
at il à cela mais le directeur des
opérations de l'organisme gouvernemental
onze mille litres de lait ont été
contrôlés vous avez écopé de 27 mille
roupies d'amandes en tout
il ya des personnes qui mélange des
engrais de la lessive en poudre des
produits chimiques ou du lait en poudre
et font l'objet d'une répression massive
nous menons des raids nous lançons des
poursuites pénales contre eux ils sont
arrêtés par la police il faut les
coupables ont ouvert le feu sur notre
équipe et heureusement nous avons
survécu mais ils ont été gravement
blessés
plusieurs saisies de fall est fabriqué à
partir de savon ou de fertilisants ont
été réalisés au cours de ces dernières
années
l'impact sur la santé de cette
consommation de lait frelaté ou de
mauvaise qualité et désastreuse
s'alarment les médecins cet hôpital
reçoit chaque semaine des patients dont
les symptômes ne laisse aucun doute sur
l'origine de leurs malles
tout à fait approprié
ils m'ont expliqué cité pêcheurs la
plupart des patients qui viennent
consulter pour un direct chronique une
gastrite ou même un cancer de l'estomac
lorsque les observons leurs antécédents
médicaux nous nous apercevons qu'ils
consomment du lait non pasteurisé et en
vrac
90% des pakistanais consomment du lait
cru vendus en vrac car celui ci n'est
pas taxi contrairement au lait en brique
ou non du en magasin